- Hi friends, it's me again.
Still getting close to Christmas time.
You know, I was sitting up
and I was thinking about,
you know,
how much money I spent
in my crack addiction.
Now, to me as a normal person,
it didn't really seem
like that much money.
But when I sat down, I got
to think about the money
I didn't have for my
daughter for Christmas.
And I don't have a car.
I wanted to get a motorcycle
and I just fucked off, you know, money.
But anyway, I started out,
I had a job,
the first job I got I got a job
at the Probation Department
in Torrance, California.
Got a job at a probation department.
And I wasn't really used
to getting high that much.
And I hated that job
because I had to sit behind a
desk and do the work and shit.
I mean all these pretty
white women running around
with their titties all hanging out.
I'm looking at titties more
than I'm doing the work.
I couldn't hear the computer.
So, my friend came over my house one day.
He had a Thai joint.
Hey man, let's smoke some
weed before you go to work.
No man, I couldn't smoke no weed
before I gotta go to work, man.
I done smoked some weed
before I went to work
and there's this white
girl named Linda, man.
They had me stackin' some
paperwork in the back
because I couldn't do the hands on work.
And she'd come back there
and she had this little skirt on.
And I'm looking at her and shit.
I say, Linda, you won't take a hit,
you wanna smoke some joint?
Yeah so anyway, we went
out and smoked a joint.
Well, she has some rocks.
She wanted to put a rock in the joint.
We were out to lunch time,
so then she put a rock in the joint.
Very first time I hit that shit,
I spent 200 fuckin' dollars.
I'm not fuckin' shittin' y'all.
I spent 200 fucking dollars.
And I said, what the fuck?
Now, back then I had a just
a little bit of control.
I would say I have had
a little bit of control
because every time was,
I've always had a job.
You know, I could get a job
because I felt like,
you know, my dad told me
if you don't have a job,
you're not a man and
all this kind of shit.
But back in the,
I know I'm an addict now.
But before I knew I was
a compulsive addict,
I didn't know all of these things.
But I know when I got paid,
I didn't like going to the bank.
Fuck that shit.
Take my money and go into the bank?
Give these motherfuckers my money?
I'll put it in my pocket.
I'll be all right.
Let's talk polite.
For one day I had,
one day I had $300 in my pocket.
Friend of mine wanted to go
over to this girl's house.
He wanted to sit down and you know
and do whatever they're doing.
And they have some of
this rock shit, whatever.
Back in the 80's it was real rock.
It wasn't this bullshit.
This was real cocaine.
I mean, when you take a hit off that shit,
you was goin' to go find
you some panties to get in.
I mean, I don't give a damn
what kind of panties they were,
boy panties, girl panties.
You just wanted to get in
some panties, God damn it.
So anyway, (laughs)
I keep it real.
So anyway (laughs)
Boy panties, girl panties, panties.
Pull it out, let's do it.
(laughs)
Anyway.
So, I had like 250,
I remember I had got a ticket
and I had a ticket to pay.
I said, I got to pay it.
I had to go to Torrance to
pay this god damn ticket.
Down there in Torrance,
fucking with them white girls.
Anyway, I had to go pay the ticket.
And the girl said, wanna take a hit?
I said, well, I've got $250.
Bam.
If you took a hit of the
mother fuckin' cocaine,
she gave me some head and all that shit.
And I said, damn, that was okay.
But I fucked off my $250.
Now I told myself never, ever, ever again.
Oh my God, no way.
No way.
Would I ever do that again?
No, not me.
Not me.
I think about,
I started working for Gary Dairy Research
about two weeks later.
I got a job through a little
tip agency I use to work for.
So, I got a job at Gary.
They wanted me to work in the store.
It had all these different parts
they wanted me to keep up with,
which I was good
because I've always
been good with numbers.
With spelling, I can't spell
but I can't even spell my own name.
But numbers, I've always been
kind of good with numbers.
And they had me up in
there, Gary Dairy Research.
And it's just the devil, man.
And I was walking away.
I had a little sports car
and I was walking out of the job one day.
This girl says, hey man, I
see you coming from Compton.
Do you live in?
Yeah, I live in Compton.
Yeah.
Well, can you give me a ride home?
Oh man, I turned Marissa,
whatever her name was.
She had these big fucking thighs
and she would always
wear these short pants.
Now, I had a girlfriend at time.
I'll tell her about my girlfriend.
Now, I was,
Let me go back.
Now, me and Robin,
let me do it good.
Me and Robin had got a
bank account together.
Oh.
We started loading the
bank account up together.
Now, I was,
Now, I mean, the lady was,
the lady was just as sweet, you know.
And I was really putting
the money in the bank.
And one day I decided to take a hit.
I took a hit off at that cocaine.
Next thing you know, I
at the Pussycat Theater
looking at porno movies,
gettin' my dick sucked
by whoever was suckin' the mother fucker.
They smokin' my dick
and I was smokin' crack.
And they said, hey man, you got,
we put you out.
Every time you come in
here, you do that shit.
They put me out the Pussycat
Theater for smokin' crack.
Yeah, I was so,
I would do that every Saturday.
I'll get me fridded out of the crack.
I was hm-mm.
Well, anyway, I was with this girl.
I had five,
we had five grand in the bank.
In two weeks I smoked up $5,000.
Oh my God, I don't feel good about that.
Anyway.
She came to me and she said, baby,
she said, I went to the bank
and our money was kind of short.
You need to tell me where
my fuckin' money went.
I came up with this great idea.
I lost the card the other day.
And I couldn't remember the number.
So I'd staple the four digit on the back.
They must've gotten
the money out the bank.
She kinda believed me but
she didn't believe it.
That was $5,000.
I got a job at Northern
Electronics with my bad ass.
So, how'd they put me?
They put me in the tool crib.
I don't know nothin'
about no God damn tools.
They put me in a tool crib.
I knew this guy, who knew
my dad, who got me in.
He got me in the job.
And I was supposed to work,
but anyway, I was making
like a grand a week.
Now, I was staying with her.
You understand, see.
I was staying with her.
Was she liked my,
she liked that dick.
I mean, I could
I would dick her.
She liked that dick.
I was dickin' her real good.
Now, she would,
in a minute.
My mother told me when I was a little boy.
She said, boy,
She said, when you give
a woman some good dick
she can't even think.
And I never ever forgot that.
So, I knew if I could put my feet,
Y'all know my mother, sir.
When I on,
oh, I'm a dicker.
I'm dickin' this lady, man
and she can't see nothin'.
So, one day, when I got paid on Friday
we were supposed to go out to this club.
She wanted to go out to this club
and I had about $100.
I had a $1200 in my pocket.
And I had bought like $50 for the crack.
And she wanted,
I wanted her to go on out to the club.
Just go on out to the club.
She comes home.
She doubles back.
I done took a hit.
I got my porno on.
And I got my thing in my hand.
I'm watching my porno.
She bust in the door.
That's why your dick don't get hard.
You're doin' that shit.
Could you imagine?
I'm so embarrassed.
I'm sittin' there's a pipe, still smoking.
(laughs)
Holy shit.
This is what I feel this moment.
I didn't do nothin'.
(laughs)
And then she goes,
this is funny.
She lays down on the
couch she opens her legs.
she's like, come on baby, gimme some.
I got to say it.
When I ain't doing that
shit, I got the biggest.
But if I take a hit off
that shit, I need to tweak.
I can't find that.
I don't know where it go.
(laughs)
I can't find that mother fucker for shit.
It be so little.
And she knew.
But anyway,
we put some more money in the bank.
Another $5,000 in the bank
and I fucked it off and
she told her mother.
Oh my God, I feel so bad.
Oh, I feel so bad.
God her poor mother said,
you motherfucker.
You messed up my daughter's money.
You need to stay away from my daughter
before I put this 45 in your mouth
and blow your God damn head off.
And I was like, yes, Ma'am.
I fucked that up.
I had the most beautiful 260Z sports car
because I built that mother fucker.
I like to tell you, I got,
I know I coulda got 25,
30 grand for that car.
I like to tell you, I
got that kind of money.
I sold that mother fucker for a $40 rock.
I could hear the car zoomin'
around the neighborhood
and I ain't got no car.
I ran outta dope.
I had to call my sister to come get me.
Where's your car?
Luckily, that time I got it back
'cause the person I was staying
with, knew who the guy was.
He called the police
and the sheriff made
him give me my car back.
My ass went back to the same neighborhood.
He wasn't there.
Somebody else was there.
No, that wasn't the time.
That's the time I spent the,
here's the last time I saw the car.
For a $40 rock.
$40 worth of cocaine, I
gave him a $35,000 car.
And I could hear him
zoomin' around the hood.
I never saw that car again.
Without a car.
I had a Buick Somerset Regal.
I let a guy use it.
I was livin' in Texas.
I did let a guy use it for a $20 rock.
Next thing I know, I see
him at the gas station.
The police are pullin'
the seats out of the car.
Everything out of the car.
I had about a $20,000 car.
(claps hands)
Bam, that's gone.
So, 35,000, $20,000,
Plus a two, $5,000.
We addin' 'em up.
Northern.
If I worked for Northern, I was makin',
let's say I was making 900
fuckin' dollars a week.
And I was smoking up 700 of that shit.
Easy.
I couldn't see it.
So, some reason, thanks
to the grace of God,
I could maintain.
For some reason I could,
I could, I could,
they call me a function,
I could function.
You know, I could kinda keep
a car and do some things.
And I always had an office.
I mean, I always had a nice,
I always had a nice woman with a good job.
A nice, nice lady.
Cause I've was dickin'.
And I know how to dick and I know how to,
excuse my expression on the YouTube.
I knew how to suck a mother fuckin' pussy.
So, I learn in a young age.
So, that's what I was doin'.
I mean, some women do the,
I learned how to do like a man, a gigolo.
My grandmother called,
my grandma'd say you fucking gigolo.
(laughs) There's nothin'
wrong with gigolo.
I felt so liked.
Anyway, I'm gonna talk
about the money I stole.
I stole,
oh my God.
Ah.
My grandmother had,
I went in her purse.
I took some money to get high one day.
My Grandma was the best thing,
was the best thing I ever had.
The best damn Grandmother.
And I told her.
I was like, Grandma, I got a drug problem.
I'm so sorry for taking your money.
I'm so sorry.
And she said,
I love you, man.
I ain't worried about that money.
I'm just glad you told me the truth.
I fucked off the couple
hundred dollars of her
I sold two $1500 bass guitars.
This is why I ain't never told nobody.
Somebody in my family
had just got engaged.
$10,000 ring.
I got high enough, sold it
for a $50 rock.
That $21,000 ring.
Oo, that hurt.
Oh, that hurt.
But anyway,
take use of it
That one hurt.
Ah, it's gettin' me.
Oh, it's gettin' me.
Anyway, I was thinkin' about
all the cigarettes I bought.
They call me Cisco.
I drank fuckin' Cisco wine by the fifth
like it was fuckin' Kool-Aid.
Wait, let me back up.
I started driving a truck.
And the poor people
would just give me money.
If I didn't have no money, I
didn't have nowhere to stay.
I lived in a fuckin' truck.
Hey man, I need $200.
I have, look,
I have been all over this
fuckin' country buyin' crack.
They should have had me for a,
if they had me for,
I coulda been a millionaire.
If they've had me for a tester,
just the police will say,
hey, let's have you test.
I know where all the dope spots is
at all the major cities
in the whole fuckin' United States.
And they got the universal language.
You see me pull up in the truck,
just like the niggas
here's what they do.
They do that then they already know.
When I'm pulling up, get
your ass in the truck.
I'm spendin',
okay.
I worked for Bestpack Warehouse.
I worked for Bestpack
Warehouse for four years.
I made 600 a week.
I'd handle where to stay.
Every fuckin' week I
smoked the whole fuckin',
So, let's do the math.
We do,
wait a minute.
For three years, 600 a week.
Three years straight I fucked off $600.
Not counting the money I was borrowing
for the cigarettes and
the wine and the hookers.
Oh my God.
I fucked around one time
and went out to that fuckin'
Bunny Ranch thing they had
at the God damn,
I got an income tax check.
Income tax check.
I had $7,000.
I went to the Bunny Ranch over there.
I went and got me three big old,
big old titty white girl.
I got this big old titty white girl.
And the white girl was
smoking crack like I was.
And let me you somethin'.
I like to say I had more fun.
I didn't get no pussy.
I didn't.
I just,
they just,
I just smoked crack
but the guard was outside the door.
He didn't know better.
He smoked all outside the door.
Just let me smoke like I wanna smoke.
(snorts)
And I got,
I got so high one night,
I couldn't survive.
And I told,
I called my sister.
I said, baby, I need to come home.
I can't take this shit.
She called.
Get him home.
She sent me money to get on the bus.
I smoked that up.
About another $200.
Bam, another $200 gone
like a mother fucker
Up in mother fuckin' smoke.
No wonder I ain't lost
my mother fuckin' mind.
Oh my God.
So, when
I first got on SSI
they gave me a check for
3,700 mother fuckin' dollars.
This is what I said.
I'm gonna take a couple hundred dollars,
I'm gonna set it to the side.
I'm gonna let my momma hold this for me.
Jeanie, why don't ya hold that for me?
My other sister, hold that for me.
I'm not gonna come get it.
And God damn me.
In two weeks, I was
knocking on everybody's door
at three o'clock in the
mother fuckin' morning.
(claps hands)
Give me my
mother fuckin' money.
(laughs)
I was, give me my mother fuckin',
I went through that money
in three fuckin' weeks.
Now, that's not talking about
the alcohol, the hookers
and the cigarettes that
went with that shit.
(snorts)
Oh my gosh.
We already talked about these 200,000,
200, 250 thousand.
We already talked about at
least 250, 300 thousand.
Now, I got a job goin' cross country.
That year I made 48 grand
and I smoked up, I know, 40 of it.
I know I did.
I tried to handle with it,
I know I fucked off four.
I know I did.
And I just,
and I would just,
I would get my money
and I pull up in the truck stop
and the little girl would get on the mic.
That shoulda been the end of any devil.
And just sayin' to me,
I'm always a pervert.
He's sendin' them young girls.
And then young girls,
that's I was in Oklahoma City,
that girl told me,
the girl told they was six,
I said, baby, you too,
you 16 years old.
You're too young.
That mother fucker.
That white girl, she pulled
out them knockers over there
and I saw that hill that there.
I said, well, how much money do you need?
I mean, we in it.
Well, there we go again.
I fucked off another $600.
I was,
God, I fucked off a lot of money.
I got to the point, I'm not interested in,
I used to like,
you know, if I,
cause I like Porsches, man.
I know every model, every
engine, the tires are going on.
I'm a Porsche fanatic.
And I fucked off enough
to get three mother
fuckin' Porsches, you know.
I have a baby that's 18 years old
and pretty much I ain't done shit for her.
And I give her every time I see her
I give her a hundred dollars,
which is once a year,
once every two years.
And I figured that's goin' to be okay.
That shit ain't okay.
It don't feel okay.
It's not okay.
And I tell my,
but see now, I used to
get a social security.
Now I don't get no
social security no more.
So, now I got to come up with
the money to pay the rent.
And most of the time I'll make it
but I always got a lean on my brothers.
He been comin' too.
I gotta lean.
But I think about,
I've been here.
When I first became homeless this time,
for three years straight,
do the math.
They gave me 960, some dollars a month.
I smoked up every fuckin',
can handle with the state.
I would get my check.
I'd get a room.
I'd get me a couple of white girls.
We smoke up all the mother fuckin' money.
I did it week after week,
after week, after week.
And I kept telling myself this
week goin' to be different.
Now, wait a minute
Now, this week I'm just gonna get one 20.
This week. I'm just gonna get one dime.
This week I'm just gonna
get one little hit.
And I'm not gonna never do that no more.
And sit there smokin' the whole God damn,
I said, you know what?
Let me tell you about telephones.
Oh my God.
Metro PCS, the girl down at the place,
when she sees me, she's so happy.
he gonna buy another phone.
I bought a phone for two years.
Every fuckin' month I pay $100
to get the phone turned on
and you give $100 for the phone.
Everything.
And the next month,
I done sold the God damn phone
and I gotta get another phone.
When she see me comin', Mr.
Banks, I got one for ya.
I got one.
I knew you was comin'.
I got one for ya.
Oh, my God.
The people know me by name.
I'm too embarrassed.
I'm looking around. (laughs)
Fuckin' people comin'
to the mother fucker.
But I kept tellin' myself,
Now, next month you won't get me.
They won't get me.
So, they talked me into spending $300.
I said, well, I'll spend $300
on a Galaxy S5, whatever.
I get the $300 Galaxy.
And I know I done spent my money
but God damn you,
before the night's over,
the nigga bought the 350,
and he gave me a $50
rock for a $300 Galaxy.
That $300 Galaxy,
(snaps fingers)
that mother fucker was gone. (laughs)
$300 Galaxy.
I can't win for losin' with this shit.
But I'll tell you what,
I ain't gonna do it no fuckin' more.
God damn, be the next month before the,
I got to,
when I get the,
when the day come.
That day on the first,
God damn, the money,
come on at 11 o'clock,
I'm at the liquor store.
The dude that work the liquor store,
he got the bottle of brandy on the table,
'cause he know what I want.
It's already up there.
He know I'm gonna make the mother fuckin',
save some money in the first deal
'cause then he gonna,
he gonna pull it down for the first deal
He gonna spend some money.
The old man wave some little
corner around the liquor store.
I'm goin' there.
There little old white girl.
She knows she likes to suck my dick.
She waiting on me.
They all waiting on me.
This month I'm just
going to spend just $100.
Wait, wait, wait.
Now, I'm gonna show you all this time.
I'm just gonna spend a hundred.
That's it.
I mean,
y'all not gonna,
y'all not gonna guess this right.
I'm just gonna,
Before you knew it, the whole,
two day later, the
whole God damn 900 gone.
I did week after week, after week
after week, after week and then I stopped
til the next week.
And I did a week after week, (laughs)
after week, after week.
But the thing is, I'm
laughing about it now
because I cry.
But I'm laughing now because
it's insane.
But that's addiction, man.
This mother fuckin' crack.
And let me tell you the funny
thing about the mother fucker.
When you hit the mother fucker,
man, whew.
When you hit that that
mother fuckin' pipe,
let me tell you something, y'all.
For y'all that never did it,
don't ever fuck with
that mother fuckin' pipe
'cause that mother
fuckin' pipe feel better
than busting a nut in a 16 year old girl.
I'm gonna tell you that shit.
But after that one, you don't get nothin'.
Normally you chasin', you chasin',
you chasin' you, chasin' it.
And you can't get it.
And I take a hit and here come the rats.
I'm not scared of men.
I'm terrified of rats.
I don't know why.
I take a hit, I get paranoid.
I do.
Here come the rats.
(laughs) I tell you rats, sometimes,
I'm looking for the rats.
(laughs)
One time, me and a friend
of mine were smoking crack
and she had this closet was into the side
and I don't know what made that little,
that little mother fucker
come around the corner.
He looked at me like, yeah, mother fucker,
I know you're scared of me.
(sucks teeth)
Man, I jumped up on top
of that God damn toilet.
And that woman, she,
I never heard a woman.
She said, you fuckin' pussy.
You scared of a fucking rat.
I was so scared of this fuckin' rat, dude,
my fuckin' leg,
I couldn't,
I couldn't move.
I mean, that scared the shit outta me.
Oh my God.
But now where I'm stayin' at now,
it keeps me from runnin' at night
'cause if I'm paranoid,
I ain't goin' to get in no drunken fight.
You walk down the streets over here,
you see, man, them God
damn rats get to runnin'.
But I ain't gonna,
How did I get on rats?
Anyway.
I just let it sit here and talk.
So, we look at the money I spent.
I mean, dude, I spent,
God,
God, I know I
I coulda had a house.
I coulda had a black 911.
I could have a black GT.
I want a GT3.
I want a black GT3 with custom rims on it.
I wanted it sittin' in my God damn garage
with a custom tail and the
roll bar and all that shit.
I could have paid cash for,
What are they?
100, 120,000.
I coulda paid cash for one
of them mother fuckers.
And coulda paid cash for a house.
I love Santa Monica.
Santa Monica and I like,
I like Redondo Beach and Santa Monica,
or Malibu.
I coulda bought a house over there
and had me some little big leg white girl.
We coulda been kickin' back,
we coulda been goin' to church
and you know, could have
bought a little Mercedes.
I liked the commercial when the guy,
lady buys two watches
well, he goes out and buys two trucks.
He says, I got you a truck and me a truck.
And I sit there, I cry.
I'm like, damn, I wish I could do that.
Man, I wish I could do that.
You know, meet a lady, you know,
and just give her everything, you know.
And then I met this bonehead.
I met this girl.
She's hot.
Dude, let me tell you, she's hot.
She's blacker than that mother fuck,
she's blacker than a black po,
You ever seen the black police truck?
She blacker than a police truck,
but she fine.
I mean, she's about,
she used to tumble, tumble.
That mother fucker got legs and she,
the way she walk.
So I met her.
I take her to the house.
She wants to sit and watch
scary movies all God damn day.
Oh, she in there
Anyway, I wanted a hit.
I take over to the house.
Let me tell you how I fucked that off.
I bought her a mother
fuckin' fifth of liquor.
Oh my God.
Took her to the beach.
Choose her, looking at some girl.
And then we come home.
She finds my crack pipe sittin'
on the counter with a rock.
She said, oh my God.
Do you do that?
Oh no, uh-uh.
I don't,
You people, oh,
(hiccups)
I would have never came over.
Uh-uh.
You do that?
The shame,
the remorse and the guilt is indescribable
I feel this fuckin' low.
She said, you a nice guy, man,
but you do that, I don't wanna be,
I know what y'all doin'.
Y'all get high on that shit,
you'll fuck anything.
I was so hurt.
I finally met a nice girl.
Anyway,
that's what happened.
So, all in all, here comes Christmas time.
I might have,
I didn't have fifty cents
in my God damn pocket
to buy cigarettes with.
I said, well,
I was glad because we couldn't
visit nobody on Thanksgiving
because I didn't have
$100 to give my family.
I didn't have it.
Oh my God.
So, that's where I am.
And I like to come
because I like the people that come to me.
I know my friends are there.
What's up, y'all.
I know my friends are there
'cause they always see me.
I just met that guy
and I never got your guy's name.
What's up, dude?
What's up, girl?
I know you're there.
I mean, come say hi to me when you see me.
I got more stories
but I just I appreciate
you guys listening to 'em
because it gives me a chance
to get off of this shit.
And I hope the dude that
get behind the camera
ain't gonna tell nobody that.
I certainly hope nobody don't know.
If y'all look, y'all hear me talk about,
let me tell you what I
appreciate about you guys.
You guys never accused me.
You never down me.
You never talk,
You guys always give me praise
because I know I'm sayin' things
that you guys want to hear
because you went through the same thing.
Y'all I'm not the only
one, mother fuckers.
I know.
I know y'all are out here.
I see you out there sayin', ah.
- [Interviewer] Except a lot of people
don't like you because
- He's tellin my story.
I'm tellin' your story, homey.
Anyway.
- [Interviewer] A lot of
people come down on you
because you had that
relationship with a young girl.
- Yeah.
Let me tell you something.
Everybody got skeletons in their closet.
Ain't nobody in his world
ain't never did nothin'.
There's a whole lot of
other shit I ain't did.
I'm gonna,
me and my buddy had me there,
I'm gonna tell all y'all
because you guys,
you can process that
shit however you want to
but for me, it showed me,
I gotta,
I'm getting off that shit
and it's doin' me some good, sir.
- [Interviewer] Are
these talks helping you?
- So, fuck y'all.
No, y'all my friends now.
So, fuck y'all.
No.
- [Interviewer] Are
these talks helping you?
- Oh, they help me tremendously.
Because they,
Okay, they have me on psych meds.
And one psych med I had
to take three times a day.
And I'm not,
I don't take that shit anymore
because what I,
what I needed,
I needed,
I needed to tell the truth.
They told me one time you
can't poke holes in the truth.
God loves the truth.
God don't love a lie.
You got to tell the truth.
People, if you wanna get some therapy,
tell on yourself.
That's the best way.
Therapy.
It ain't what no,
don't worry about what nobody figured,
what nobody gonna say.
Tell on yourself.
Put your shit out there on the,
put your shit out there
put your shit out there on the plate
and let mother fuckers eat it.
If everybody processes it,
oh well.
You feel better.
With that, I'm out.
(both laugh)